ينضموا الينا الان من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه
اهلا بك اللواء فايز الدويري يتحدث عن هذه
القنابل
عنقوديه او ذخائر العنقوديه التي تطالب
بها اوكرانيا الان يعني لماذا تثير كل هذا
السجال تلك الذخائر العنقوديه واذا كانت
بهذه الاهميه لماذا تاخر طلب اوكرانيا لها
حتى الان
يعني دعيني اجيب على ما انهيت به سؤالك
لماذا هذا التاخير لانه
المساعدات الغربيه هي بدات بعمليه تصاعديه
بدات صواريخ جافلين
واستمرت تصعيد في التزويد حسب المقتضيات
الميدانيه والاحتياجات حتى وصلت الى
الدبابات لبارد او ابرامز صواريخ
فايف او صواريخ هي مارس والباتريوت
والحديث الان حول طائرات اف 16 اذا هناك
مسار مسار تصعيدي في نوعيه السلاح وكميه
السلاح خلال الاشهر سته عشر الماضيه لكن
لماذا هذه الضجه حولها الان هذه التوقيت
التوقيت جاء في فتره حرجه جدا بالنسبه
للجانب الاوكراني لان الهجوم
لمضاد والاوكرانيا يقول المرحله التمهيديه
لم تحقق النتائج المرجوه حققت انجازات لكن
ليس كما كانت التوقعات المشكله الرئيسيه
تكمن في الخطه الدفاعيه وطبيعه التحصينات
والخنادق واستخدامها
مظلات واقيه او اماكن حاميه للجنود
وبالتالي تاثير القنابل العنقوديه في بعض
الحالات وحسب حجم الحاضرين تغطي منطقه 200
ب 400 متر الحاضرين الواحده والقنيبل
الواحده تتشذى الى ثلاث مائه شظيه اذا هي
تخدم القوات المهاجمه وترهق القوات
المدافعه هذا الجانب الاول الجانب الثاني
اللواء فايز يعني
تقول روسيا بان هذه الدخائر تشكل خطرا
فعليا كما تقول على حياه المدنيين هل يمكن
فعلا مراقبه استخدام هذه الذخائر والتاكد
من يعني كيفيه استخدامها
يعني هناك
اشتراطات على الجانب الاوكراني بعض
التقارير اشارت الى انها اشتراطات مكتوبه
ان تستخدم بالاتجاه الصحيح لانه استخدامها
لا يعتبر خرقا للقانون الدولي لماذا لان
التصنيف القانون الدولي يعتمد على طبيعه
الهدف وليس على نوعيه السلاح وبالتالي
اوكرانيا التزمت بانها ستستخدمها ضد
القوات العسكريه وليس ضد المناطق الماهوله
او تواجد المدنيين هذا الالتزام هل تطبقه
ام لا تطبقه الايام هي التي ستكشف طيب
فيما يتعلق بالتحالف الدولي الذي اعلنت
عنه اوكرانيا لتدريب القوات الجويه على اف
16 الى اي مدى من السهوله دخول هذه
المقاتلات الى ساحه المعركه برايك لواء
فايز
يعني الان العمليه الدخول الى متطلبات
المتطلب الاول والاساس ان تكون هناك
الاطقم سواء كانت الطيارين او الفنيين
المساعدين او الاطقم المسانده المسانده
جاهزه
لاستيعاب هذا السلاح والتعامل معه بمهنيه
وحرفيه عاليه الان بدات عمليه التدريب
الحديث عن وصول هذه الطائرات من المتوقع
ان تصل في الخريف او في نهايه الخريف
وبالتالي الان وجود التحالف تحالف من 11
دوله هذه هي الدول التي لديها خبرات في
استخدام هذه الطائرات على سبيل المثال
المانيا اعتذرت وقالت لا توجد لدي طائرات
اف 16 ولا استطيع التدريب عليها اذا هي
احد عشر دوله لديها الخبرات الفنيه
للتدريب وبالتالي من اجل تجهيز الاطقم
التي ستتعامل مع هذه الطائرات لانه بدون
هذه الاطقم لا فائده من وجود الطائرات
اشكرك من عمان لواء فايز الدويريه الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي